this video is sponsored by mie get your
30-day free trial at movie.com
thomasl this unassuming little moment is
an example of what I think makes the
curse one of the most brilliant shows to
air
recently um I was oh sorry are you in
the middle of in this line something
feels off from another moment in the
show holds the key to understanding both
its Brilliance and why it's so
uncomfortable to watch I mean it's
edited
well let me explain in this scene douge
a TV producer has just shown Whitney the
cut of their HDTV show they're working
on together she can't put her finger on
exactly what doesn't feel right about it
but she knows something feels off her
show doesn't feel like what she expects
a reality TV show to feel like the
answer to why it doesn't feel that way
lies in a few moments that happened
earlier in the show so we got to film
this all right absolutely not no come on
we're making a show about your life
that's enough that's enough what Whitney
is watching here is a reality TV show
that doesn't alter reality to make it
more dramatic or exploit real personal
drama in order to make a truly engaging
show by reality TV standards what we
have here is a frictionless show there's
no conflict there's no drama and that's
not something people want to watch so
what do people want to watch We Buy
Houses for cash sight unseen sold you
bought it this is season 1 episode 13 of
hgtv's Flip or Flop the show that
perhaps most influenced the curses fake
HGTV show this episode starts like many
others TK and Christina are hanging out
in their home chatting about the latest
slew of forclosures but then a hint of
conflict a little drama starts to creep
in okay so honey what are we saying
we're spending about4 million dollars on
it are you sure you want to risk that
much money I mean we have maxed all our
credit cards we borrowed against our
rental property I don't know it's just
really scary what's the worst that can
happen we lose it all this isn't Wild by
reality TV show standards you got to
have high state
but then on the way to the Foreclosure
auction the couple starts to get into
another argument about the maximum bid
don't go over what if it sells for $269
over $1,000 we're losing this house the
max is$ 268 are you listening yeah fine
seriously you always do this you might
wonder if they're playing this up for
the camera or if this is real conflict
it feels pretty real to me but either
way it's kind of weird it begins to lend
the show a sort of
just watching to see them make money
flipping houses now viewers might be
scrutinizing their relationship to see
what's really going on people apparently
find this Dynamic engaging because it's
one of the most successful HGTV shows
ever by season 7 they were divorced but
still continued doing the show together
for another five seasons shows like this
are ruthlessly edited and constructed to
be maximally engaging dramatic
entertaining and interesting Flip or
Flop like many other unscripted shows
are not above manipul population and
exploitation sometimes you can tell
they're just making up a scenario to
manufacture more drama for the show and
sometimes they're exploiting the drama
of their own lives but the weird thing
about unscripted reality shows is that
part of their conceit is that what
you're seeing happen is real even though
we all hopefully know by now that that's
not the case part of the fun of watching
reality TV is the way the shows pretend
that you're seeing reality when you
watch them reality TV is an actually
showing you something that's necessarily
more real than scripted TV reality TV is
really just a specific type of stylistic
realism the Brilliance of the curse lies
in part with how it plays directly
against the reality TV style of realism
it doesn't just comment on how reality
TV manipulates reality but shows us how
with the very way it's scripted and shot
its exploration of reality and realism
has implications for how we see
ourselves and how we live our day-to-day
lives
[Music]
without further Ado smoker
allowed when you become obsessed with
creating realism you create something
fake when you become obsessed with
recreating reality you create something
hilarious that's the opening line of an
essay writer director and actor Benny
safy wrote about the show Nathan For You
in cinemascope magazine who at the time
was working on his adrenaline infused
crime Thriller good time fell in love
with Nathan for you writing that he
repeatedly had to pause the television
so that he could cry from laughter I
really felt a connection to what Nathan
was doing on his show with regards to
realism what particularly impressed
safty he calls it Nathan's Masterpiece
was a season 3 episode titled smokers
alow is it a loophole or yeah loophole
it's the loophole theater law in this
episode of Nathan for you Nathan is
trying to help a struggling bar owner
increase business by exploiting a legal
loophole that allows indoor smoking as
long as the smoker is part of a stage
performance Nathan being the Twisted
genius that he is sets up two chairs at
the back of the bar sells tickets and
the evening of non-actors just going
about a normal night at the bar becomes
a show this is funny enough on its own
but the Twist and where it really
enthralled safy was where it goes from
here oh man they were awesome yeah yeah
they they were awesome the two patrons
of the show end up actually enjoying it
and the character of Nathan in the show
believes he stumbled upon a hit play but
he misunderstands why the patrons
actually enjoyed it instead of realizing
the play was interesting because it was
actually real he thinks the audience
must have enjoyed it because of the
specific things that happened that night
he becomes obsessed with recreating the
reality that was the first night of the
performance safy writes Fielder the
character is convinced it is not the
concept that is successful ful but the
content it's a study between actual
reality and meticulous realism in
misunderstanding authenticity and
performance as safy wrote when you
become obsessed with recreating reality
you can create something
hilarious that line could easily be
about the curse a show created by safy
and her together after they met and a
friendship turned into a collaboration
let's do that
again like the sweater yeah it's exactly
us in one scene Asher and Whitney share
a playfully funny moment together and
Whitney has the idea to recreate it for
her Instagram just exactly like that
okay just struggle with the zipper when
she does this she makes the same mistake
the character of Nathan did in smokers
aloud she thinks it's the content of the
moment that other people will enjoy and
attempts to recreate that reality for
for her Instagram not understanding that
what made the moment funny to her and
Asher was the authenticity of it on the
surface the curse is a show about newly
married real estate developers Asher and
Whitney and their lonely alcoholic
producer friend douge attempting to
create an HGTV reality show with the
focus on sustainability and having a
positive impact in their Community oh
and I curse you Asher gets
cursed okay but to really understand
what the curse is doing we need to
understand its stylistic concept and
what makes it so different from not just
a reality show like Flip or Flop but
pretty much every scripted show out
there as
[Music]
well the curse is not doing a parody of
an HGTV show although I wouldn't blame
you if like me this is what you thought
when you first started watching it opens
behind the scenes of the show Whitney
and Asher are creating and it's both
painfully awkward and a bit Darkly funny
to watch as we realize the subjects of
their show aren't performing gratitude
for the camera in the way they would
like for the Show Mommy happy son has a
job right there's conflict over how to
proceed here Whitney and Asher are
uncomfortable forcing what they need out
of the subjects in order to make an
engaging show while dougy always a
master manipulator is willing to do
whatever it takes after this scene we go
straight into a clip of the show they're
making all my invisible homes are Net
Zero structures and this might feel like
parody but parody is about deliberately
exaggerating aspects of something for
comedic effect and if you've watched a
decent amount of HDTV like I have at
this point researching this video you
know that this fake HGTV show isn't
really an
exaggeration one of the things the curse
does is Imagine fairly realistically
what the behind the scenes dynamic might
be in a situation like the one the real
Christina and TK lived through instead
of a parody The Curse is doing something
much stranger and I think ultimately
more interesting here is actually doing
a pretty sincere character study of a
couple making an HDTV show yeah the
curse is satirical but it's showing
fairly realistically how I think a
couple could start out producing a show
with certain ideals and then slowly get
pulled into creating artifice and
playing up drama or revealing their own
drama for the sake of having a more
interesting show because you want the
show to succeed I wanted to be the guy
with the long hair and the woman with
the baby as a family and they can be
curious about the house but not critical
it shows how you might start out
resistant to any kind of manipulation of
reality or inclusion of personal
conflict but how these ideals might
slowly get chipped away and compromised
due to the pressure of just getting this
the show made and put on air I know that
you have a vision that you want to
spread around the world right but in
order for that to happen you need people
to watch the show Whitney and Asher
aren't supposed to be a direct
representation of TK and Christina
whitne Ash are updated for 2023
fictionalized and based on some of the
other HGTV hosts as well but I think
they are written to be realistic their
Show's concept isn't absurd or
Ridiculous by HDTV standards and Asher
douge and Whitney aren't even that
exaggerated as characters yeah it's
played up a little bit for comedic
effect but I think only slightly I mean
have you noticed how absurd actual
reality TV shows are or have you noticed
how weird real people can be when you're
not seeing them through the curated
filter of PR and social media these
clips we see of flip anthropy Are Pitch
Perfect Fielder's experience in the
unscripted TV World shines through and
they don't feel like imitations of a
reality TV show they feel like an actual
reality TV show but while they wanted to
make the fake show on the show as real
as possible their stylistic concept for
the curse itself was to create something
that felt as far from anything else on
TV as was reasonably possible this is
most immediately obvious just in the
cinematography and the way the show is
shot but I think where the difference is
actually most significant and impactful
is in how scenes are constructed and
edited
where a show like Flip or Flop or let's
be honest basically any show tries to
cut out everything that won't be
interesting or dramatic or push the plot
of the episode forward safy and fielder
said what if we made a show that focuses
on those moments that would get cut out
of every unscripted show or would never
get scripted into a fictional show in
the first place because it'd be too
awkward or boring let me show you
specifically what I mean and the way it
impacts the story story there's an
extended sequence from episode 4 that
was one of my favorite parts of the show
Asher and Whitney are on a call with
HDTV when the scene starts the call goes
on for a few minutes and then it ends
and then here the scene just continues
without any break in time or location we
go straight into what feels like another
scene where Asher and Whitney are now
talking about the call and its
ramifications this goes on for a few
minutes and then watch this I bet we
could ask way more for it
I'm going text
added the show hits a second point where
most scenes would end but then it just
keeps
going there's a long awkward pause and
then another separate unrelated
conversation starts up it's the kind of
thing that happens all the time in real
life but which I've hardly ever seen
depicted in a film or on TV that
conversation goes on for a while until
it's interrupted by the doorbell
they go see who's at the door and it's a
neighbor they have a conversation with
the neighbor about something totally
unrelated to what's been happening in
the scene so far and because of this
conversation Whitney decides to go talk
to another of the neighbors here's how
most shows would handle this moment we
will handle this Maria I I promise you
I'm so sorry this happened thank you
again oh hey Whitney let's pop in all
here's what actually happens on the
curse we follow Whitney as she gets
ready to leave walks outside looks at
her car and then decides to walk to the
neighbor and yet again the scene just
keeps going in real time the show
follows her on her walk we're still in
the same scene right now as the phone
call five conversations earlier the
sequence continues as Whitney talks to
the neighbor and then walks back home it
only occasionally Cuts back to Asher in
the house but the whole time it's
maintaining a sense that this is all
happening in real time the entire
sequence is about 15 minutes long why do
I think this is brilliant for one thing
it's the exact opposite of reality TV
show editing which has to stitch
together a narrative out of a ton of
different disconnected moments instead
here we have one long moment with many
different narratives playing out inside
of it which is much closer to how things
happen in real life and acts as a kind
of CounterPoint to the reality TV show
segments but it's also brilliant because
of what is revealed in these little in
between moments that would normally get
cut out when they get off the phone
because it doesn't cut to a new scene we
see how quickly Whitney's demeanor
changes we talk to you soon
by did you hear that stuff that she was
saying about the displaced residence
which reveals how performative her
excitement was by leaving this awkward
break in we see how Whitney decides
she's going to say something but has to
work up the courage to mention it to
Asher it gives us some insight into the
Dynamics of their relationship and how
she feels uncomfortable being totally
honest with him and when we follow her
on her walk it's kind of a profound
moment because we've only experienced
fragments of the location and the
neighborhood as it's been talked about
and seen on the show but Whitney's love
for Espanola and the community is a big
plot point in the series as we follow
her on her walk we begin to see the real
community that lies just outside of the
boundary of where she lives and what the
show has shown us so far we get to see
the sense of connection that Whitney
feels to the people and the place but it
also kind of highlights the somewhat
absurd nature of where she's chosen to
build these ridiculous invisible homes
and how out of place they actually are
within the rest of the neighborhood this
walk is something that any sane
contemporary show would cut around or
condense into a montage but by playing
things out in real time the curse
expands our sense of the location as a
real place and reveals more about the
characters pacing and constructing the
show this way acts as a kind of
commentary on the way reality TV and
regular scripted TV bends the structure
of actual reality in order to make it
more interesting engaging and
entertaining it's fine for RTV to be
interesting and entertaining but the way
media manipulates reality starts to
become a problem when it's so normalized
to us that we forget it's happening when
we begin to confuse realism with
something real and when we interact with
so much of the world and consume so many
hours of media in our modern lives we
might start to feel that something is
wrong with our own life because it
doesn't feel like any of the media we
consume realism is ultimately a
stylistic attempt to make the way a
piece of media manipulates reality
invisible it looked like you were like
holding the shirt back so it looked fake
I think a recreation of reality isn't
necessarily any more real But it
includes the parts of reality that media
usually leaves
out the curse leaves all the awkward
stuff in not just because it's a
commentary on media but because the
dramatic core of the show is the
characters struggle to remove those
things from how they perform themselves
to the world I think exploring this is
significant and important because these
same ideas apply to social media
podcasts and news media and these days
so much of our idea of the world and
people and life comes from this media
world that many of us spend hours a day
inside we're surrounded by media that
carefully constructs an image of Reality
by curating what you see and what you
don't see and to grab and keep our
attention all of these media evolved as
a matter of survival towards depicting
the most interesting and
attention-grabbing stuff what is
entertaining dramatic shocking or funny
and if you don't want your viewers to
click away and watch something else you
remove everything that would make it
feel awkward confusing genuinely
uncomfortable or worst of all boring but
here's the thing a lot of life isn't
dramatic or interesting or funny at
least not in the way we want it to be a
lot of life is boring and uncomfortable
and awkward that's not all life is but
that's normal and it's a part of life
that rarely gets depicted in media
because of media's bias towards the
things that will grab our attention in a
lot of ways we like media because it's
showing us the parts of life that aren't
in our normal life it's a concentrated
form of all the parts of life that we
like that we get to consume we use media
to escape the boring uncomfortable parts
of life to not have to sit with
ourselves and explore our own boring
annoying self-consciousness the curse
includes and focuses on these things
which means it risks alienating some
viewers but I think this element is also
what ends up making the curse
artistically compelling because we stand
to actually learn a lot from directing
our gaze towards the parts of life that
we want to cut out but this isn't just
highlighting how media shapes reality
for us as the viewers it's about how we
all perform and shape our reality in
both real life and through the media and
to really drive that point home we have
to see these characters lives in the way
they don't want us to see them and yeah
it's easy to point fingers at reality TV
producers and hosts most of us hopefully
aren't as fake in our lives as Asher
douge and Whitney are but we all are to
some extent and could all stand to
examine that a little bit when we see
the truth of how a character really
feels show up on their face once they
finally stop performing for the camera
or the people around them and think they
are no longer being watched it holds a
mirror up to how performative Modern
Life can
be I already have no responsibility you
know it's like a freak accident I happen
to get hit there's a weird quirk in the
character of douge that helps us
understand what the show is saying about
its characters douge backstory is that
his wife was killed in a car accident
while he was drunk driving and I was
slightly over the limit so everybody of
course is like oh you were drunk he
doesn't take any responsibility for the
crash but it clearly haunts him that's
kind of all I think about
really because of this he has this habit
of using a breathalyzer to check if he's
over the legal limit and he stops
driving if he is he's attempting to do
the right thing here but the way he goes
about this reveals something about how
all the shows lead characters interact
with their own moral responsibility
douge seemingly doesn't want to drive
drunk because that would be bad and
wrong but instead of just not doing it
at all he becomes obsessed with the
specific rules he just wants to be
technically in the right he's not
worried about digging any deeper into
whether his alcoholism in general is a
problem and leading him to make poor
decisions that put people in danger he's
just trying to make himself feel better
by checking the somewhat arbitrary box
of having a blood alcohol content of
0.07 instead of
0.08 what
078 I'm
good nice that's right on top of all
this he seems to only remember to use
the breathalyzer once he's already
driving instead of thinking things
through ahead of time he feels a Pang of
self-conscious guilt once he's already
in the act and then feels compelled to
confirm whether or not he's right this
is the exact same pattern we see play
out with Whitney and her show she wants
to do the right thing by not pushing
locals out of their neighborhood through
gentrification she wants to make sure
she's properly representing the local
native culture in her show but instead
of making sure these things are solidly
taken care of before she moves forward
she only starts really taking care of
them once things are already in motion
and then once she does she's really
mostly interested in appeasing her own
guilt by being able to check a box that
reassures her that she's technically in
the right that's whose validation I need
to feel comfortable putting what we're
doing on here she's ultimately
interested in appearing like a good
person both to the people around her and
to herself I'm not really sure what you
want me to say I think you can just say
um my homes are so unique and um so
important as a piece of Art and as far
as Asher goes he's completely defined
his sense of what is good by what
Whitney wants him to do all three of
these characters rather than grappling
with the difficult and messy reality of
their own moral responsibility for
things focus on doing what they think
will make them look good to themselves
to a specific group of people or to
their partner Cara Durand the native
performance artist in the show is kind
of a Counterpoint to this she becomes
uncomfortable with the way Whitney Bo
dies into her Own performativity Your
Homes are so
unique and so important as a piece of
art and I couldn't be more proud to have
my work displayed
inside that is so sweet that means so
much to me and decides to opt out
entirely okay but what about the curse
you might be thinking people want to
know what the show is about what the
ending means and there are a lot of
theories some of them are better than
others perhaps the curse has just
finally caught up with him perhaps
Whitney just wished he'd go away and so
he did as he promised in the previous
episode he would and if you didn't want
to be with me and I actually truly felt
that I'd be gone you wouldn't have to
say it I would feel it and I would
disappear y Asher Ashman how you doing
exciting stuff huh big day in many ways
though I think how Asher is treated at
the end is a reflection of how Asher and
Whitney treat others throughout the show
instead of slowing down examining what's
actually happening really listening to
Asher and asking him what would help him
douge and the firefighters barge forward
with their idea of what will help they
throw Asher a net but it's not actually
to help it's only as a symbolic gesture
to get him to calm down while they
continue with their own approach to
helping him this is the same way Whitney
and Asher have been helping their
Community we wanted to know if you if
you'd like to do security for the plaza
for a little bit uh just while while the
stores are closed just same rates same
hours
okay when they're met with a lack of
enthusiasm from the people they're
trying to help instead of slowing down
to see what the people they're trying to
help really need they barge ahead with
their own idea of what is
needed I don't think the curse is
interesting because of a specific thing
that happens in it or because of a neat
and tidy explanation for all the events
that take place place it's interesting
because it's a distorted reflection of
our own
reality it's interesting because of the
way the show shows us the parts of life
that we desperately want to cut out it's
interesting because how different it
feels from other media why does Asher
get cursed and fly away at the end I
ultimately think the answer is right
there in the show I just want to make a
great show I want to make a great show
that people are going to watch The Curse
still has to get your attention keep it
and get people talking about it it's
still a show in the modern TV landscape
you know our show barely got picked up
right really yeah the show yes when
Asher flies up into the tree and Benny
safy one of the creators of the show as
douge the creator of a fake show within
the show says this is incredible he's
right it's just great TV Fielder's other
work exists within a kind of
unresolvable paradox it's always
attempting to get at some kind of
reality in an inherently fictional
medium and this show is no different I
think if the curse accomplishes anything
it's to break the illusion of realism
because how do you capture the reality
that trying to capture reality
inherently distorts it without making
something
[Music]
absurd one of my favorite movies from
last year was fallen leaves a finnished
film from director Aki kosaki like the
curse it also kind of Revels in these
tiny awkward details of life and finds
poignant drama in the moments sort of
between the moments it's very
beautifully shot it has a dead pan sense
of humor and one of the best uses of
Music out of any film I saw last year
and I definitely recommend you check it
out fallen leaves is streaming now
exclusively on movie in North America
the UK Ireland Latin America India and
turkey and you can watch it for free
when you sign up for a 30-day extended
free trial of movie using my link that's
mubi.com
flight in addition to fallen leaves they
have a huge hand curated library that
they're always adding to it's one of my
favorite places to find and watch Cinema
on the internet click the link on the
screen to check it out today go to
movie.com
[Music]
thomasl